Привет! В этом уроке у нас аудит и консистентность между экранами. К этому моменту у нас в проекте уже есть минимум четыре экрана, в моём случае есть ещё несколько модальных окон, а также лендинг из Cloud Design. Это уже не один экран, это целая маленькая система. Именно сейчас она начинает или не начинает разъезжаться. Любая дизайн-система разъезжается, как только экранов становится больше двух. Это нормально, так бывает, но без аудита расхождение копий,
копятся незаметно. И главный антипаттерн в этой работе почти такие же, но чуть другие компоненты. На одном экране мы отвязали instance, что-то поменяли, на другом экране сделать этого не стали, но поставили другие размеры, скрыли какой-нибудь из элементов и так далее. В итоге у нас через 10 экранов будет 10 немного разных карточек, немного разных вариаций одного и того же, и никто уже не вспомнит, какая из них правильная. Урок закрывает эту дыру, директива Screens Audit сканирует все собранные
экраны, сверяет с каталогом и возвращает отчет. И главное отличие этой директивы от того, что мы делали до этого. Она только читает и сообщает. Ничего не пишет фигма и в каталог без явного апрува, вернее даже твоей просьбы. По умолчанию она работает именно в режиме чтения.
Итак, давайте разберемся, как обычно, из чего директива состоит, что она конкретно ищет. Она проводит 6 проверок, всегда одинаковых. Итак, первое. Каждый компонент на экране должен быть instance из компонент set, не frame с похожей геометрией. Если нашелся frame, имитирующий компонент из дизайн-системы, это баг, так быть не должно.
Второе. Все цвета, заливки, обводки, эффекты должны быть привязаны к переменам. Вставленный кодом цвет, выбранный там просто из палитры, это уже баг.
Третье. Дубликаты компонентов. Два. Компонент set с похожими именами и анатомией. Это кандидаты на объединение.
Такое тоже бывает, как раз таки, если у нас некорректно связался агент с той дизайн-системой, которая у нас уже есть, и насоздавал одинаковых сущностей, которые используются в разных экранах.
Мы их можем запросто объединить. Тут аудит, уже последний такой, аванпост проверки, что нигде у нас ничего лишнего не создалось.
Четвертое. Это неиспользуемые компоненты. То, что мы создали, но нигде это так и не пригодилось.
Возможно, какие-то экраны были удалены, что-то пересобрано и так далее. Находим те компоненты, которые нам не нужны.
Не будем копить весь этот мусор и переполнять контекст.
Пятое. Расхождение состояния. Один компонент button используется на пяти экранах, на четырех в обычном виде, на пятом с кастомным стилем, отвязанным от компонента.
Это сигнал. Либо в дизайн-системе не хватает нужного варианта, либо случайно отвязали instance от мастер-компонента.
И шестое. Это покрытие edge cases. Проводим еще одну проверку на предмет edge cases, насколько у нас закрыта полнота нашего flow.
Проходит полностью весь аудит по вот этим шести критериям, шести направлениям и нам выдается отчет с предложениями по решению тех или иных проблем.
Мы уже говорим агенту, нужно это исправлять или нет. Все ок.
У нашего агента есть полный перечень компонентов, есть их назначение, есть их состояние.
Он понимает, что у нас есть, зачем, как оно будет использоваться, какие должно иметь вариации.
И в принципе даже логически может это все дело додумывать.
Поэтому знает, какие состояния для каких компонентов, для каких объектов нужны.
И выдает, что у нас есть, а чего нам не хватает.
Итак, проходит аудит, находится ряд ошибок и давайте разделим проблемы, которые нужно решить на то, что делаем мы и что можно доверить агенту.
Во-первых, что можно доверить агенту?
К отвязанному компоненту вернуть привязку, заменить что-то, какой-то фрейм на уже существующий компонент.
Также забить цвет в переменные или проставить эти переменные соответствующим цветом.
Удалить неиспользуемые компоненты, то есть все те задачи, где логика достаточно примитивная.
Если же у нас непонятный нейминг, дублирование компонентов, возможно отсутствие каких-то состояний уникальных, тех, которые ему сложно предугадать.
Здесь уже требуется наше вмешательство, наша полноценная работа над этим компонентом, его доработка.
В любом случае агент полностью все задачи не закроет.
Нужно это все опрубить, самостоятельно дорабатывать.
И в этом случае ты можешь как делать все руками и просто ему сообщать о том, что я что-то внес, что-то изменил.
Так и определить как бы общее направление того, что нужно исправить, сформулировать как именно это нужно исправить и передать ему, чтобы он это осуществил.
Так это тоже прекрасно работает.
Итак, как обычно я запустил директиву, он подготовил отчет и прошелся ровно по всем тем пунктам, тем разделам, о которых я говорил ранее.
Во-первых, сначала нашел отвязные элементы вместо instant.
Например, navbar.
У меня navbar менялся, я его отвязывал, перемещал и не вносил изменения в компонент, а просто дублировал тот фрейм, который один раз сделал.
Он это нашел и предлагает решение, либо расширить navbar мастер слотом для юзер, либо удалить navbar как избыточный и зафиксировать уже ту композицию, которая сейчас используется.
Здесь, опять же повторюсь, он нам предлагает пути решения, он нам сообщает об ошибках и мы сами уже принимаем решение, как эти ошибки править.
Ну, конечно, можем его попросить применить на свое усмотрение то решение, которое ему кажется наиболее правильным.
Также нашел, что у нас здесь есть заливки и обводки без привязки к конкретным переменным, тоже нужно их добавить.
Также нашел дубликаты компонентов, ну, здесь их немного, но вот конкретно с карточкой он говорит, что выглядит это подозрительно.
У нас очень много карточек, возможно, что-то из этого можно сократить.
Также нашел здесь, например, у нас есть карточка просто карт, нет ни одного instance.
Также есть модалка и есть три варианта этих модалки, то есть три фрейма модалки, но ни одна из них не привязана к этому компоненту.
Тут нужно либо обновить каталог компонентов, либо заменить эти фреймы на те, которые будут именно дочерними компонентами этой модалки.
Далее у нас расхождение в состояниях, тоже смотрим, что у нас используется, что нет.
Здесь, например, для кнопки у нас 13 неиспользуемых, hover, disabled, loading, focus и так далее.
Ну, здесь это на самом деле и не нужно, у нас это уже в интерактивном варианте, эти состояния будут проявляться.
Далее, покрытие состояния, здесь он выводит, какие еще нужны нам состояния, например, дашборд, нужно состояние загрузки, если у нас данные устаревшие, если у нас данные только что обновленные.
Все это нужно предусмотреть.
То есть он не просто какие-то общие формулировки предлагает, а опирается на назначение этого блока и уже исходя из этого предугадывает эти edge case, те состояния, которые нужно предусмотреть.
Также, например, с модалками нам нужно еще предусмотреть состояние отправки, состояние успеха, ошибку на input.
У нас этого нет, это нужно предусмотреть и он нам об этом сообщает.
Ну и в конечном итоге выдает по каждому разделу какое-то краткое summary, в котором предлагает, как мы можем все эти проблемы исправить.
Ну и также небольшое расхождение, что сейчас в документе Components MD, в котором у нас должна быть вся структура описана, есть только 15 компонентов, а в Figma на самом деле у нас 18.
Нужно докинуть 3 недостающих.
Это тоже важно, поддерживать апдейты этой системы для того, чтобы она хорошо работала.
Теперь подводим итог, когда нам нужно вообще запускать этот аудит.
Во-первых, было бы хорошо после каждого нового экрана, но в принципе это долго, это запарно и, наверное, никто так делать не будет, но лишним это не будет.
Также уже более реалистичный вариант, раз в спринт, то есть мы отрабатываем новый флоу, новый набор каких-то экранов, новый функционал.
Сначала собираем его, потом прогоняем наш аудит.
Также обязательно перед передачей в разработку, перед какими-то ключевыми моментами мы проводим полный аудит, это обязательно.
Ну и совершенно не обязательно после каждой сущности, компоненты, какого-то маленького модального окна запускать аудит.
Смысла в этом нет, проводится он достаточно быстро, поэтому от того, что ты сначала накопишь какой-то объем материала, а потом проведешь аудит, ты ничего не потеряешь.
В качестве домашнего задания тебе точно так же нужно прогнать аудит, сделать скриншот отчета, в котором отсутствуют какие-то критические ошибки или сообщение о том, что мы все критические ошибки исправили, все супер.
И ссылка на фигму, в которой просто комментом, красным кружочком, рамкой, чем бы то ни было еще, отметишь, где какая там ключевая оправка была исправлена.
На этом все, удачи с выполнением домашнего задания и увидимся в следующем уроке.